Okay, so for your first homework, what I'd like you to do is get a basic web app online.
This is going to be the foundation for what we're doing in the rest of this class.
So step 1 will be install Google App Engine.
We'll include documentation in the course notes for how to do this,
and you can also use Google's own instructions online.
And we want to install the Python version.
Put online a basic app. All it has to do is print out the words, "Hello, Udacity!"
Nothing fancy.
Just basically get this thing online, and when you've got that working,
submit the URL here.
I'll show you what it looks like on my browser, or my version of it.
Here we are. This is what I've installed.
You can see it's running on appspot.com, which is Google App Engine's domain by default.
All it does is has a simple webpage that prints out, Hello, Udacity!
This is the entire homework. If you get this working, you have succeeded.
For some of you, this should only take 15 minutes or so,
but I realize that installing web apps and packages and things like this
can sometimes be troublesome.
So once we've got this working, we'll have a good foundation to build on
for the rest of the course. Okay, good luck!